workers first combine water canola oil
and sugar then they add pureed banana
and mix until the ingredients are well
blended they add wheat flour then sea
salt baking soda and preservatives such
as citric acid routinely used in
packaged foods to prevent the growth of
bacteria and mold the final ingredients
are eggs and chocolate chips a pump
moves the finished batter from the
mixing bowl to a large hopper that feeds
the automated production line then the
pans enter the depositor which Strauss
1.5 ounces of batter into each loaf
cavity this one batch of batter produces
6666 loaves the filled pans enter a
multi-level vertical oven in which they
zigzag up and down 13 baking zones of
varying temperatures after 27 minutes
the loaves are fully baked
however they can't be packaged yet
because they're piping hot
so the next station on the line is a
multi-level vertical cooling chamber its
fans draw out the hot air while blowers
introduce filtered cold air when the
pans exit the cooling chamber about 25
minutes later the loaves are just
slightly warm a robot now descends on to
pans at a time it jabs the loaves with
needles to lift them out then withdraws
the needles to drop them on a conveyor
belt that's ventilated to help the
loaves finish cooling this belt
transfers them to a narrower one that
leads to the packaging area their
workers line up the lobes in single file
on a track that leads to the rapping
machine each loaf is roughly three and a
half by two inches and one and a half
inches high even though each one started
out as one and a half ounces of batter
some moisture evaporated during baking
producing the final loaf weight to one
point four ounces
under the watchful eye of a sensor the
loaves enter the rapping machine where
printed transparent film envelops them
the two edges of the film overlap
slightly underneath the loaves the
machine seals the edges with a
combination of heat and pressure
then it simultaneously seals and cuts
the film in between the loaves each
chocolate chip banana loaf is now
individually wrapped